next one not to take away from the
seriousness
of what you two have achieved in the
seals but i would like tony to tell a
funny story about jocko the reason i put
this one in here
uh of course i don't like to hear any
humor or any laughter in the world
but there was a bunch of people that
that said this so uh
anyways i figured you might have a story
i got like like seriously like a million
like a million i mean that story about
you and your roommate
like you're uh you're like
you guys live together in coronado yeah
you know i'm talking about
the big fella yeah you're like i was
over there partying one night we're
getting gooned up
and you're like you know what our our
bill was from domino's
it was like 2 500 last month
in a month i thought that was so funny
had some wicked good parties though yeah
yeah we did have some pretty good
parties and then
one time we're out at an island so it's
like two o'clock in the morning
and the guys are you know they're uh
what do you we call that after you're
done do the work on the vehicles
uh post you know post up the vehicle
stopping the vehicles
and they're all busy doing stuff and i
mean
i'd help out if i had to but i mean
that's not my job so
and they boys know what to do jeremy had
him
great lpo and uh we're sitting there i
mean you and leif and maybe
one of the other jo's shooting the [ __ ]
about something
i mean i had to do a work because what
else is there
and life was talking it was quiet kinda
and
you got your arm on one of the humvees
and all of a sudden you just out of
nowhere you just
kick the dirt and you go god damn it
you're like shaking your head and
clenching your face and like
the [ __ ] you talking about and he just
like looked at me and smiled and walked
away like
what what what is wrong with you
still haven't figured out what was wrong
with you actually i i i know
i remember you just went god damn it no
i was actually getting
frustrated that there was a chance we
might not go to iraq
like i was so uh scared
and horrified of of
that it just you know and i just was
trying to control it but then it just
kind of slipped out yeah here's another
quick one about
jocko i'm like i don't know we were
there
a couple weeks in ramadi and we're just
falling into a groove operating and
one night i was in his office because
like
i couldn't sleep or whatever and uh
he's like look at this and you show me
he shows me the computer he goes
this is from my wife
are you okay you've been gone three
weeks and we haven't heard
anything from you i'm like
chum you better you better email your
wife or she's gonna fly over and kill
you
[Music]
yeah i talk about detachment a lot and
uh sometimes you know
like i said sometimes you get over there
and you got all that [ __ ] going on
and uh nothing else in the world matters
but i didn't have anything going on back
here yeah it didn't matter to me at all
sorry uh uh to my wife there uh
she i'm sure she remembers that in any
way
you did though okay i got him yeah uh
all right